a lot of cognitive loopholes and
shortcomings that inform our perception
of the world we don't see the world as
it is we see the world as we are through
a prism of expectations and cognitive
bias season but this idea that we don't
see the world as it is applies very much
to what's happening with technology and
innovation and disruption because I
believe that technology is the
embodiment of human imagination in the
world I believe that technology is the
literalization of human creativity in
the world right I believe that
technology is how we turn the human mind
inside out how we exteriorize the
contents of our mind in the world how we
literally impregnate the world with the
contents of our minds
this is the human story we are the
tool-making animal to be human is to be
trans human the creature that transcends
its limitations and expands its
boundaries
the big question is what's the
difference between the disruptions were
seeing today in the disruptions of the
past and I would say the only difference
is that these disruptions in the past
didn't happen as fast as they're
happening now so they accrued over many
generations so in the past you were born
and you died in a world that maybe saw
one transformative innovation in the
world didn't change that much within a
generational gap and so well hell the
new generation was born in a new world
that they adapted to it but today's
different because today the changes are
happening in real time
and within our own lifespans and so it's
a lot more for us to take cognitively
it's a lot more change and a lot more
uncertainty and a lot faster
[Music]
but basically digital Trent
transformation digital technology
changes at an exponential rate
but human beings are linear thinkers
this is the cognitive bias that prevents
us from making sense of what's happening
because we are still we still have a
brain that evolved in a linear and local
world and now we're trying to contend
with a global and exponential world
that's the cognitive dissonance your
intuitions continue to be linear in an
exponential world if you take 30 linear
steps right one two three four five by
step 30 you're at 30 right so 30 linear
steps gets us to 30 that's intuitive to
us because a hundred thousand years ago
there was a lion across the savanna and
it was going to run towards us we were
making a linear calculation of how
quickly it was going to get to us and
eat us again we're wired for linearity
but here's the kicker if you take the
same 30 steps those exact same 30 steps
but you take them exponentially you get
to a billion right this is the part that
always gives me pause and I've used this
example a thousand times 30 linear steps
gets you to 30 but 30 exponential steps
gets you to a billion forty years ago a
supercomputer was the size of this
building and you needed special
permission to get access to it and in 40
years that it shrunk down to a device in
your pocket that is a million times
cheaper a million times smaller and yet
a thousand times more powerful
[Music]
one of the challenges is we're
trafficking in a world of ideas and in
the media and in social media
particularly it's a race to the bottom
in the attention economy if it bleeds it
leads and that creates a warped
perception where we feel like
everything's going to hell and we have
no capacity to subvert that perception
[Music]
because we are storytelling animals we
respond to narratives right the
beginning of a personal crisis is when
the story that you tell yourself about
yourself is no longer convincing or
self-serving you know depression and
anxiety are the excessive rumination of
a story a self story that has
metastasized into one that it's like
self-destructive and so we need to like
shed our own skin shed our old skin
right we need to be willing to craft new
narratives for Humanity
[Music]
go with the internet-of-things we're
bringing animism back everything will
talk to us everything has agency and the
creative and commercial possibilities
there to transport the human experience
to realms that are far more interesting
engaging intuitive the future of
wellness the future of mental health all
this stuff we can totally play with by
creating these very interesting
immersive worlds on the back of
connectivity everywhere built customized
around every individual giving everybody
superpowers essentially
[Music]